the country wants to break apart no no i
disagree i don't know where you're
getting that info i think i i think i
think they do i think we feel a
sentiment of of of dissatisfaction i
think a lot of people i mean if you look
at the dissatisfaction rate amongst
congress members everyone's dissatisfied
with what congress is doing now people
are satisfied with what their local
congressman is doing there's polls
suggesting that but overall i think
we're down a trajectory towards an
extremely bad path i think everyone that
knows it government has been standing in
the way of free enterprise capitalistic
endeavors that have been creating such
an economic bubble that it's about to
burst and pop any time and we are about
to be put right into a situation i think
akin to the great depression especially
with the financial mess that we are all
involved in with the federal reserve
literally just printing money out of
thin air i think the financial
calamities are going to be far more
impactful than the health aspects that
we're even dealing with right now and i
think a crash is coming and when that
happens oh boy will things get worse and
the agenda will be pushed through even
more
let me ask you guys do you think that
the crash is going to result in prop and
prices collapsing or skyrocketing
inflation or deflation it's it's too
hard to tell right now to be honest with
you because of so much supply shortages
so much labor short inflation um and and
when we look at what the government's
doing now i mean they're purposely
making it that much worse they're
putting restrictions on the ports so
products can't get here there's there's
labor unions screaming at the
government's please stop stop with your
insanity stop with your madness add that
on top of labor shortages federal
mandates increasing the labor shortages
states like new york and california
farmers being told to destroy their
crops destroy their livestock we are
headed down a disastrous path and their
only way to get out of it without being
hurt is by having people break up into
their own personal individual little
units a lot of people like to group up
republicans democrats it doesn't matter
to me i think it's beyond that it's
freedom slavery which one do you believe
in and and that's that's the law that's
the line you want to live in communism
go live there uh you want to live in
freedom you want to have your own
personal choices for yourself it's
already happening people that that don't
like communism or moving out of new york
or moving out of california and they're
incentivizing states that's why there's
a whole migrant crisis on the border
because they're trying to counter that
by bringing in as many new voters as
they can as well i disagree with that
these uh illegal elements that are
coming in are being shipped all over the
country exactly but they're not they're
not i don't think they're going to get a
path of citizenship in the immediate
exactly it's going to be a long time for
now but what you need to understand
congressional seats though exactly so
this let me let me tell you this because
you might not might not know this ariel
the way we do electoral college votes
for the president is based on how many
congressional seats a state has
a state's congressional seats are based
on the amount of people there not
citizens which means if a million
illegal immigrants come in to texas
which we've seen
that means we need to give texas one
more congressional seat even though
those people aren't citizens wow that
means texas will get another electoral
college vote so they're not directly
voting in a popular vote but but they're
still they're still yeah they're still
changing elections yep wow no i didn't
know that yep so that's yeah that's
that's definitely a possibility you know
tucker carlson was like they're going to
give them a path of citizenship so they
can vote because they always vote
democrat and i'm like they don't need to
they need to only move them in to the
specific suburbs or states so they find
blue so they send them to blue states so
but however census just happened so they
have to wait 10 years for this take
effect but that's what will happen bring
in as many people as possible into blue
states to get more seats and there you
go you can you can then gain advantage
politics is all about just gaining power
they don't care how they do it they just
want to do it that's what's happening as
dianne feinstein is telling you you need
a passport permission slip just to fly
domestically inside of the united states
that's the bill that you literally
propose or a negative test or proof of
recovery
how do you prove recovery yeah
yeah so negative tests right they're
they're they're increasing the mandates
and it is really really interesting that
all of these kind of just feel like it's
like all part of something that feels
like a like a great
re-restart a great reason a great reset
yes i heard that somewhere i heard that
a great researcher a lot of times yep
now we were talking about this last year
there's a big agenda the 2030 agenda you
will have no privacy you will own
nothing you will be happy they took down
they took that website down from the
world economic forum
there's a viral video on twitter where
it's like what life will be like in 2030
you will own nothing and you will be
happy and then everyone started tweeting
it like dude look what they're saying
and then they deleted it last year i
still remember we were at the skate park
outside in the garage and i was like you
won't believe this the pope mastercard
and other multinational corporations are
coming together to try to usher in the
great reset officially
officially saying we need to change the
way things we was like economically and
no i'm serious and then it was
mainstream media news uh it wasn't even
me just you know speculating a lot of
this stuff but but again it's it's all
there it's it's all in everything that
they have prophesied that they have been
talking about they've been talking about
doing this through global warming for
such a long time the same
implementations the same things that
they called for are being implemented
and and that we're seeing the same
policies being instituted not just here
domestically in the united states but as
if it was a coordinated plan
internationally turkey just launched
domestic passport systems on planes
trains and buses to travel domestically
you need to have a vaccine passport
israel has done the same italy has done
the same france is going to be
instituting those laws when just a few
weeks ago we were told that vaccine
passports were conspiracy theories
you're crazy if you think there's going
to be vaccine passports joe biden even
told the national television no way
we're going to have vaccine mandates
what do you think like one implemented
one big tv in the nation's capital the
national television well you know what i
mean you know what i'm trying to say
here
i'm just looking for i'm just ripping
here off the top of my head i got a
bloomberg opinion article give amazon
and facebook a seat at the united
nations this is from yesterday yeah yeah
stuff from ben shot oh it's i told you
might as well
officials the clown
corporation's governments yeah yeah they
already are this is what we're trying to
make people understand what is governing
with the beginning guys yeah but this is
right the one thing you're not
considering in all of this is that
mark zuckerberg is just so cool oh yeah
he's just a really cool truth
truth and jeff bezos that's true oh the
best so cool i always liked mark
zuckerberg me too you see that 1997
interview with jeff jeff
bezos you know it'd be funny if there's
like fresh-faced he's like in you have
you seen the picture of him in that
crappy little office
it'd be funny if like it's interviewed
and they're like so what's your plans
like well i'm going to sell books and
then uh in 20 years i'll take over the
world
and make a space
shaped like those guys
those guys those guys are pretty cool
but authoritarian corporations cannot be
considered governments in this world we
cannot allow that to happen i don't care
who's in charge no human can handle that
corporations are people my friend
exactly also truth according to law
although it makes no sense according to
mitt romney i think it's legal they're
legally persons aren't they corporations
well they're i guess they're legal
entities but personhood means like they
can be sued and they function i guess
but i think people wait overestimate
what that means if you say corporation
has personhood or something it just
means you can sue them and they operate
as though you know a tax entity or
whatever from huffington post
corporations are people and they have
more rights than oh yeah they can't go
to prison
yeah sure enough what if when a
corporation broke the law they you know
put the corporation in prison so it
couldn't operate for a certain amount of
time like a regular person you could do
that digitally i would imagine just shut
the company down okay your company's
effectively shut down and they'll say
but that'll destroy my company don't
think it's funny when you send someone a
prison for five years they come out five
years culturally stunted and often don't
know i don't have skills for jobs yeah
what do you think happens when you send
people to prison when you type in
largest criminal settlement on google
yes i did that earlier today first
article that comes up is a justice.gov
link about the justice department
announcing the largest health care fraud
settlement in its history going after
pfizer that agreed to pay out 2.3
billion dollars a part of the largest
health care fraud settlement in history
of the department of justice and they
were they pled guilty to charges
relating to promoting they're not now
withdrawn uh extra pain medicine yeah
but but hey hey uh you know stephen
colbert dances and says that's good so
it has to be good yeah
youtube would take direction from a cdc
that's taking direction from pfizer is
disturbing to me that any corporation
would follow this train of command when
you see pfizer one of the 10 largest
criminal fines in history this company
what position at halliburton did dick
cheney have oh god was he the ceo
i'm pretty sure he was uh the ceo and
then what job did he get afterwards vice
presidency of the united states and then
what did the united states do after he
got elected give extremely lucrative
contracts to alabama to give inadequate
services to u.s military men that were
serving this country in iraq and
afghanistan that led them astray and
charged them to the highest degree that
they could
well you win the million dollar million
dollars luke
this my bitcoin address is
linked on linked on weirdchange.org
snap look at that
and then i guess you know you know
what's funny is we have to talk about
politics being downstream from culture
but i think the corporations finally
realized that too like republicans are
still fighting these political battles
like judges and supreme court
the corporations and the democrats uh
well i should say the corporations and
their leashed lap dogs the democrats and
their leashed lap dogs their voter base
have just gone for the cultural
institutions and that's why you know you
see what you see with like the
wilderness on youtube that's why if you
deviate from it even though you have the
same principles you always had they have
to come after you because you need to
fall in line i'm doing i'm going down
the list of the ten largest criminal
fines in history number eight is
facebook with five billion number six is
google with 9.5 billion
wow bank of america's on there but it's
also important to note here that this is
a slap on the wrist to how much money
these multinational corporations make i
mean pfizer look how much money they're
making right now they're creating more
billionaires than any other industry
than any other private company in the
world right now as we're speaking right
now with their ceo literally going on uh
national media and his voice is gospel
couple months ago he told us take the
shot everything will go back to normal
now he's telling us well you're going to
need a booster shot and then maybe we'll
go back to normal and then everyone's
literally regurgitating it as well so
wait wait wait medical
corporate
auto technocracy
brave new world yeah there you go no
it's not it's it's all of them
bravery world 1984 no it's a brave new
1984 for vendetta and then that new uh
movie that came out on amazon
a brave new fahrenheit 1984 for vendetta
and then what was that movie that they
uh stopped the second season utopia
utopia so here you wanna know what i
tweeted earlier best one ever i said
a tech billionaire concerned with
overpopulation
uh schemes a plan
to trick people into purging themselves
to save the planet
that is the plot of kingsman
and utopia
and utopia the the evil villain
literally makes fake meat
but watch kingsman it's like it's what
is this have you seen kingsman no so
samuel l jackson plays a tech
billionaire
who makes a spoiler for people haven't
seen it as an older movie but it's like
he's a few years old it's awesome
he makes sim cards for free everyone get
free cell service free internet hey
guess what who else has tried to offer
up free internet around the world couple
tech millions anyway he offers up this
thing and then what it does is
it ran at a certain point when he
activates it it makes every phone emit a
noise that inhibits people's like
judgment so they become violent and
irrational start attacking and killing
each other and he does it and he
explicitly says the earth is got a
thickness because he is a list beside
the toxins and he's like and and the
planet is overheating to kill the virus
and so his plan as a tech billionaire is
to trick everyone in taking these sim
cards so that they all will kill
themselves and depopulate the planet
utopia
have you ever seen utopia
utopia got cancelled and my
understanding is got cancelled because
it freaked people out because utopia is
about a tech mogul who's concerned about
overpopulation so he tries making fake
meat and when that isn't working and
advocating isn't changing people's minds
he orchestrates a fake pandemic
to trick people into taking a vaccine
that actually sterilizes them and in the
show
someone who is involved in the project
is giving clues in the form of a comic
two comics dystopian utopia and then
these conspiracy theorists find it and
they're like together look what this
comic is showing us is gonna happen and
the funny thing is in our reality
tv show no there's a tv show
in our reality there's a tv show called
utopia telling us that a tech mogul who
makes fake meat is concerned about
overpopulation so he's trying to get
people fixed and sterilized another
layer deep dan bird plays ian who i did
a tv show with dan bird called aliens in
america
i was on the the pilot episode with dan
but he plays a character named ian in
utopia i don't think the tv shows are
real i'm just saying how this is a
singularity is that yeah we're in a
simulation man
let me let you you don't know about the
simulation
let me tell you about the simulation all
right
i went to the we went to the casino this
weekend listen to this listen to this
story hear me out hear me out we went to
the casino this weekend
and i went uh we played we had a good
time we usually go you like look you
never go to a casino try and win big you
go with like 100 bucks to play some
table games and laugh and you get all
excited and then when you're done you're
done
so i didn't realize the casino out here
is horse racing and they were doing the
horse race and i got to watch the
horse's race it was so cool and so i was
like okay i'll play some bets they're
like two bucks and so i play some bets
ended up winning 57 well the nice old
lady who advised me and who to bet uh on
because i didn't know i said i'll give
you a tip here's 20 bucks i got 37 what
am i going to do i'm going to go the
roulette table and i'm going to put 35
bucks on 26.
so i walk up to the roulette table and
there's this guy standing in front of me
not playing and i'm sitting there like
what am i going to do am i going to be
that guy who's like excuse me if you're
not playing can i get in you're in my
way uh
i'll i'll i'll i'll wait
the lady spins the ball
26 comes up
i was i was so pissed off 26 fine it
came up and i could have been excuse me
sir and then i could have put it down on
20 on 26 and i would have won i think
you know like a grand or something
because i was just like yeah we'll do
26.
so that that pissed me off then i went
to the next roulette table because i
didn't actually play yet
and i'm with allison and with my brother
and i'm like okay i'll put on 26.
on the roulette wheel what number is
next to 26
30 and what comes up
30 and not only did 30 come up but the
ball spun and then synchronized with the
wheel and was stuck hovering for a few
seconds and i'm like what is happening
and then it goes right next to 26 and
i'm like oh and the and the dealer looks
at me he's like yeah and then it goes 30
and it's ah
now here's what happens next
so we end up coming back because we
wanted to let's bring people to the
horse races you get like a hot dog you
watch the horses and they weren't doing
live races so we were like oh we should
have checked the brochure but this time
i was like i'm going to go play i'll
play roulette again this time i'll bet
on 26.
so i i bet a couple hundred bucks
i'm putting on 26 and the surrounding
numbers
and then i'm like i'm down i'm down and
down but then finally 26 hits i win big
because i had like 25 bucks on it plus i
put bets on everything related to it so
26 is black it's even it's on the middle
rail and then so i win this huge number
and then as the dude is preparing the
chips he walked because it was the
digital one where you can watch them
spin but then he walks over to me and
right as he hands me the chips
26 black hits twice in a row
and then everyone starts laughing and
the dealer goes 26 again
and then i was just like
we live in a simulation
i don't really mean we live in a
simulation i'm just saying like what a
weird weekend it's a magnetic universe
that's for sure i actually don't i
actually believe in that i do believe in
that stuff i am a law of attraction
believing type of person and i think
there's there is science that
that supports a lot of it yeah big rose
quartz crystal right there i do believe
in that stuff i don't think it's
perfectly science but i do i do believe
i i think that's also how people are
they're using the law of attraction to
make people afraid they're continuously
talking about negative things on the
news and continuously talking about
covenant that's all people think about
it and it makes them afraid we're
negative all the time that's that's why
we did not always i think you're
critical i think that's different than
being negative but hold on that's why we
started the cast castle vlog first yeah
which is like puppies playing and the
chickens running around doing chicken
stuff and they're really funny to create
something that would like counterbalance
the content negativity and then we did
tales from the inverted world because
that's
not as upbeat fantasy well no it's real
oh it's all true stories i haven't
stopped well you just posted i didn't
watch yeah yeah all true stories
investigative paranormal stuff and
that's to inspire on the universe yes we
want people to hear that and like
reinvigorate their light for like
discovery and exploration so we don't
want it just to be doing negative news
all the time i think there's a big
difference especially with us just
recently talking about the mass movement
of people waking up the large protest
compared to the mainstream media that
literally hopes death rates go up so
their counter goes up and they can make
it big and as read as possible cnn so
cnn literally did that
and they were literally getting off and
hoping that the numbers would be higher
to have generated buster as he said and
that's that's shout out to james uh
james o'keefe and project veritas for
getting those videos out yep
there's a big difference between what
we're doing and what they're doing right
it's not all negative there's a lot of
people out there that are waking up
there's a lot of solutions just waking
up to the problem is the first step in
making the right decisions for yourself
and that gut felt segment was pretty
positive look we got we got greg
gutfeld's you know uh dominating the
late night that's fantastic we've got
people across the country chanting f joe
biden hey it's a good week huh not all
bad and i think neutral energy is
underrated you can be super critical and
be neutral about it great jedi yeah i
even saw a delete facebook trending uh
yeah and a lot of people talking about
it so maybe we could warn people to make
sure that they don't give a phone with
facebook to their adolescent child you
know thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you